in outriders the first major choice
you'll make is deciding which character
class to pick
you won't be able to change it once you
do so make sure to go with the right one
or risk having to start a new character
it's a hard choice but we're here to
help john luke max phil and i have each
played as one of outrider's four classes
devastator trickster pyromancer and
technomancer
to break down which is right for you if
you enjoy the video be sure to drop us a
like and subscribe for more video
content about outriders and other
shooter rpgs
let's start with outrider's take on the
tank class the devastator
the devastator commands gravity ripping
apart the earth around them both as a
means of protection
and offense the devastator is all about
overwhelming force and close range
combat
encouraging you to use your abilities to
stagger enemies while you repeatedly
crush them with intense damage
as a result if you go with this class
you should be opting for powerful guns
that can cut down small enemies quickly
think assault guns like assault rifles
and lmgs and especially shotguns
you should also be someone who regularly
remembers to pay attention to how you
can control the battlefield long enough
to get up close where you can do the
most damage however just because you can
rush into a fight and soak up damage
does not mean you always should
the devastator is the tank class yes but
it's a strategic tank
you can endure a bit longer than the
other classes but you will be
easily overwhelmed without a plan
interrupting and stunning enemies is
key to winning as the devastator this is
not the class for you if you want to
fight without using cover
using abilities like earthquake from
cover allows you to deal damage and
temporarily stun enemies
which you can then rush and take out
likewise you can use your abilities to
quickly get out of a jam and back to
cover as well
as a final note the devastator's unique
healing mechanic requires they must
regularly fight at close range
so you will die if you play too
carefully and always hide behind cover
at some point you do need to go out and
fight up close knowing when to pull back
and when to push forward is the trick to
mastering the devastator
it's not very hard to figure out though
and you should pick up a natural rhythm
fairly quickly
next up is the trickster or outrider's
take on the rogue class
like the devastator the trickster excels
in close range combat however this class
is more for folks who prefer hit and run
tactics
as a result cover is not your friend if
you're playing as the trickster
in fact staying in one place for too
long will almost always lead to death
through control of space and time the
trickster can teleport across the
battlefield and temporarily freeze
enemies and bullets in place
because the trickster is all about out
maneuvering the enemy through speed
grab firearms to dish out damage quickly
shotguns and fully automatic assault
guns are ideal
as are pistols or revolvers playing as
the trickster means that you need to be
someone with
excellent positional awareness
teleporting blindly is not good
as a hit and run class the trickster
excels at temporarily stunning enemies
with abilities like temporal blade
and then getting out of danger with
abilities like borrowed time
additionally the trickster has a lot of
abilities geared towards stunning
multiple targets at once in order to
give you time to focus on the biggest
threat
this is not the class for you if you
like cover based shooters the trickster
should never hide
instead relying on its abilities to
disrupt the enemy's formation
and chip away at them bit by bit this is
the class for players who like to
overwhelm an enemy through sheer
aggression
to wrap up the trickster also heals by
killing at close range
however it doesn't heal by as much as
the devastator
instead kills at close range both heal
and provide a shield for the trickster
this shield is what will protect you
long enough to rush the next enemy
without taking too much health damage
it's not much though you can't tank
shots as easily as the devastator can
the pyromancer commands fire existing as
outrider's resident mage
like the trickster the pyromancer is a
fragile class however instead of
mitigating that disadvantage with speed
the pyromancer excels in outright
firepower if outriders firearms don't
impress you nearly as much as the game's
super powered abilities
then the pyromancer is for you which
isn't to say that you won't be using
guns
if you go pyromancer you'll likely be
rocking mid to long range weapons like
semi-automatic assault guns
and sniper rifles but the pyromancer is
the only class to have an innate boost
to its ability damage
and most of the cooldowns on its
abilities are pretty fast this is
outriders only class where you should
always be leading an attack with your
abilities
for lack of a better term going with
pyromancer is a slow burn
this class eventually becomes incredibly
powerful but it doesn't start out that
way
in fact of all four classes the
pyromancer may be the hardest one to
start with
doesn't truly come into its own until
you've unlocked enough abilities to pose
a threat
on top of that the pyromancer can't
simply kill enemies to heal like the
other classes
it first needs to mark targets with
abilities and then kill them
early on when you only have one or two
abilities that can be tricky
as a result the pyromancer is one of
outrider's classes that struggles a bit
when you're playing on your own consider
only going with this class if you know
you're good at cover based shooters
or you plan on teaming up with friends
that said like we said before the
pyromancer is a powerful class once
you've unlocked a few abilities
many of its powers are geared towards
keeping enemies at bay like heatwave
others like thermal bomb can cause
massive chain reactions of damage
the pyromancer is all about using your
powers to keep enemies just far enough
away that they can't overwhelm you but
also just close enough that you can use
your abilities to kill half a dozen at
once and get all your health back
it's a tricky class to master much more
so than the devastator and trickster
and finally there's the technomancer
which is the closest outraiders has to a
summoner class
only instead of calling in beasts to
help you during combat the technomancer
uses its powers to summon gadgets like
mines
turrets and rocket launchers the
technomancer excels at a distance
using its abilities to freeze and poison
any enemy that tries to get too close
enemies can also be slowed or distracted
with turrets and once the enemy is
weakened from poison or frozen in place
they're an easy headshot away from death
as a result the tecnomancer is the class
for those who enjoy using precision
based weapons like long range rifles and
snipers
but the technomancer is also the class
for folks who like coming up with cool
combos when fighting at close
range the technomancer doesn't have much
in ways of utility
so this class needs to build good high
damage combos to deal with threats
before they close in
for example one of the technomancer's
best combos is freezing an enemy and
then using pain launcher which causes
your helpless foe to soak up a ton of
damage all at once
the technomancer is an outlier that is
the only class that doesn't heal through
killing enemies
you instead heal by a fraction of how
much damage you deal against an enemy
it's not by much though so you don't
want to get too close to enemies and get
overwhelmed
beyond the incentive of not dying the
technomancer also has another reason for
being outrider's default long range
class
of all the classes the technomancer is
the only one to gain increased damage
when fighting from long range
so when you fight from afar you both
deal more damage and heal by a greater
amount
and that's our breakdown of out writers
four classes now that you know how they
work
which class are you going for oh you end
up trying a few let us know in the
comments below
and be sure to subscribe so that you
don't miss out on more outriders
coverage like our tips you should know
and video review
[Music]
you